hey everyone in Sarah thread sterner  sorry end calm and today we're going to  demonstrate how to do the swing to gate  and the swing through gate while using  crutches and let the names help you so  the swing to gate is where the patient  will move both crutches forward then  they will hint swing or move both legs  forward and place them at the placement  of where the crutches are located  now the swing through  is very similar to this they will move  both crutches forward then they will  move both legs forward can't swing both  legs forward but they will swing it pass  the crutch placement  thank you so much for watching and don't  forget to subscribe to our channel for  more videos